perhaps the most famous institution
throughout the history of East Germany
was its secret police force the ministry
for state security better known as the
Stasi now the Stasi a well known mostly
because of how incredibly effective they
were at their jobs that being the
suppression of dissent spying on the
broader East German population and
conducting espionage across the Western
world but how did the Stasi work where
did it come from and what happened to it
after the reunification of Germany well
the Stasi was founded in nineteen fifty
one year after East Germany itself with
the man called Vilhelm Zeisler at the
helm size' tried to remove the East
German first secretary Volta Oh bricked
in 1953 but failed and so was himself
ousted he was replaced by ernst von
Weber who was shortly after was replaced
himself by Arish Milka who kept his job
until 1989 all three of these men were
former Soviet intelligence agents and
were seen to be low to Moscow which was
the point the Intelligence Agency
founded across the Eastern Bloc at this
point were first and foremost loyal to
the center of the Communist world and
not their own nations the Stasi was
founded not to protect East Germany
itself but to protect the interests of
the socialist Unity Party therein
although those in charge would have
undoubtedly argued that those were the
same thing in fact one of the issues the
Stasi had at the beginning of its
inception was that it could only recruit
fresh people and not intelligence
veterans why well because all of
Germany's previous intelligence officers
had worked for the Third Reich and thus
were seen as untrustworthy so how was
the Stasi organized well Milka stood at
the top of the Stasi and reported
directly to the Communist leadership
from the Stasi headquarters in East
Berlin
most of his operations were focused on
East Germany itself except for one
section the hva which conducted
international espionage this was mostly
focused on West Germany and ultimately
this is something the Stasi were very
good at it operated his own well trained
guards unit maintained jails for
political prisoners and spied on
soldiers to make sure none of them
disagreed with the government of course
the Stars his primary role was to spy on
the East German population and boy did
it at its height in the 1980s the Stasi
had over 90,000 official employees
backed up by several hundred thousand
informants out of a population of just
over 16 million those who complained too
often or was seen as being outright
hostile to the communist leadership
would often find themselves as political
prisoners the Stasi also routinely
intercepted and monitored communications
between people especially those between
East and West Germany and it focused a
lot of resources on catching people who
were illegally consuming West German
media the level of surveillance in East
Germany was remarkably high in most
citizens there were
point or another on the receiving end of
Stasi inquiries which is why it was so
hated by the East German population yet
despite staggering levels of
surveillance the Stasi were unable to
prevent to predict the 1989 revolution
and the reason why was that they
overestimated the commitment of everyday
East Germans to communism the Stars he
assumed that membership of the social
Unity Party meant that a person liked
communism whereas actually people joined
it to advance their careers
thus when Gorbachev left East Germany to
its own devices and the people there
started to demand reforms the Stasi
thought that it wouldn't go anywhere
thus when party members and leading
officials started to demand change
particularly with respect to the
security forces the Stasi were
blindsided after reunification those who
would work for the Stasi were for the
most part fired and there were attempts
to prosecute Stasi higher-ups but the
vast majority of these went nowhere in
1990 the Stasi was disbanded yet its
legacy and the reputation of its workers
is still fiercely debated in Germany
today I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching with extra
thanks to these patrons you can see on
screen for their continued support and
an extra special thanks to James
Bissonnette David archaeologists as ARCA
Flash Danny Maloney party-boy Koch
coolin Castleman Rob Waterhouse Chris
wicker Gustav Swan David Silverman
Winston Kate woods Christian checky
Maggie packs Kowski Lexi Schwinn Anthony
Beckett
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell Mike
spinning three plates are on the white
and Michael Reynolds